Wow
my name's Greg who are you is Luka torta
what are you doing here you're here to
film with me ah makes sense so Jess and
I we're back together at it again we're
gonna check out the saddest Thai
commercial called sister there's English
subtitles on here are you a crier I am
definitely a crier I cried every movie I
cried and Straight Outta Compton Wow a
lot of people did I cried in Pokemon
when all the Pokemon thought Ash was
dead and then Pikachu was like pika Chu
I kept trying to wake up ash but he was
like frozen solid but then eventually
all the pokemons tears brought ash back
to life oh my goodness and you cried
mm-hmm did you know that very sweet
I looked up recently the benefits of
crime almost every article said even
like WebMD stated that shedding tears is
actually a more powerful antidepressant
than any other pharmaceutical ever
that's amazing
I always feel amazing after I cry yeah a
good cry is necessary so we better cry
Thai people clink oh yeah that time so
she read me what different she'd were
here we considered is running on time
anyhow
bankia ketone cake gua been para think
our fact is a Latina die
no reason to camera now monkey to me I
shall die
normal so one-third are [ __ ] up a guitar
motion the funky
quite different if I think dragon Tessa
Maya is the most impressing commercial
I've ever see laia live and I
my momma
senator Chile one condition jacked up an
octave she with Marcus the gliding for
the Dolomites I fish and yummy she
become
seeking occasion to remember my marshes
and holy
I can't believe that is a commercial
[ __ ] tie beetle your stupid [ __ ]
silly commercials if I was literally by
myself I would be like I can't I marry
try to lie yesterday yes serves my
brother's birthday and he nope can't do
this okay I've cried way too many times
let's talk about it later
you know I'm not opposed against crying
no I just know I'm gonna fall again I
didn't start talking about it well it's
my brother's birthday yesterday and like
my brother and I like we had a lot of
trouble growing up and we didn't become
close to like a couple years ago this is
talking to someone today about how about
how I felt like I could have gotten to
know my sister a little more growing up
- he recently posted a video his channel
showing that my dad did pass away about
three years ago he put together this
footage I was like 45 minutes of videos
from before my brother was born all the
way you know leading up to a little
before my dad died so it's like 45
minutes collected and okay Jessa all
right whoa my world does not understand
when you start to ball in front of a
camera let's keep going oh I love it
you're human yeah our human get me
siblings I do held uh 35 and 34 Wow and
what are you like 31 I'm 25 we're half I
grew up with them I don't ever feel like
they're my half siblings we're very
close and obviously we weren't close
growing up I mean as close as we are now
cuz they were so much older they're my
best friends
it just really should feel sad if you
like hmm why don't we do this video
first chance it what are we doing it's
just I I know it's like to not be close
with your siblings and then I'm so sorry
Jess
I really thought this is gonna be like
something that what is that emotional
and I'm glad you love this we just
talked about it you need crying is the
best therapy I just I think I know it's
like to not be closer to sit until
reject that yeah and then you grow up
and you realize like I just bit
emotionally closed off and rejected love
and compassion towards family I've been
in a situation like this is my siblings
but I know what it's like to have a lot
of regret of not loving what you should
have and that's all this is not the
environment for this
okay thanks Jess it is nothing or my
totally cool crying except for on a
YouTube channel that cool Wow
fun video for you guys see ya sadist I
commercials that this really is one of
this is because at first it was like
just so depressed that I was like this
ain't even gonna get make me like
emotional cuz I'm like this is just way
too sad like it's to intentionally said
yeah I mean they just touch on
everything honestly act of love can make
me cry more than anything else
yeah do y'all like I'm not getting along
and hating and crying is like something
that like you know yeah
those kind of emotions are usually just
symptoms of blocking something that's
underneath yeah so when they put their
guard down better their walls are
revealed that's what can get me to like
feel emotional you know and it's
important keep your guard down I feel
like as a guy can be harder to keep your
guard down yeah because guys are like
example a you cry as a guy a lot of guys
won't be like [ __ ] or something but say
well say what sir I feel good crying
I'll I just Eagle translates a little
weird I'm gonna YouTube video for more
fun videos
this is subscribe today Jesse Lucca
Tuerto has an Instagram where she looks
awesome in it my god and then she has a
channel where she also looks awesome in
it with another girl who also looks
awesome sweet eats YouTube channel and
where you can learn how to be healthy
and delicious same time ashton mo nature
watches video i know ain't got no it
yeah animal be huh funny thai people
that's gonna be Ashton's we're sorry you
guys it Oh Ashton yeah I imagine he'll
respond alright this video is done